why is Jen Ortega in New Zealand
shooting that film X and I I was there
for maybe about three months I was only
in the North Island we shot in
Wellington I love that I I genuinely
would move there I love their
appreciation for their culture of the
Maori people and how they make conscious
effort to keep it alive and also some of
the sweetest people I've ever met
there's people that I met during that
that short shoot that I I still am in
contact with to this day does Jenna
Ortega survive in x
the movie's been out long enough I get a
gunshot to the Head yeah I just had to
lay in the corner Dead with a prosthetic
on my face that gave me a cut and it was
funny because when I met Tim Burton for
my Wednesday audition I had just
finished doing that so I had stage blood
and glycerin sweat in my hair and a
massive cut on my face and had been up
for over 24 hours I got on the zoom and
he actually left it made me laugh I
thought it was I thought it was indeed